[Music]  dunno what kind of creature waits for  its own slaughter sheep the Knights of  the iron Legion were once unconquered  bull no longer they now bend the knee to  lords and ladies who have forsaken the  wisdom of war the samurai of the dawn  empire are fearless disciplined warriors  yet their emperor dishonours them with  his laws and decrees  for peace most heartbreaking perhaps are  the war boy the vikings these ferocious  plans have set aside their axes for  their feeble and  they're cowards we must be brave for  them we cannot hope to trigger war  everywhere we can if we recruit our  enemies to the cause  this will be an age of wool  how dare you thousands of my people dead  well here's your chance for vengeance  here in your warriors will learn to live  like the rest of us  apollyon played us all one against the  other  so watch to weed out the weak  I took an oath to fight for peace so did  you  show me the  I